are you ready santa barbara for the next
two contestants on american duo
[Applause]
show out
ready
[Applause]
[Music]
all right give it up for sean spinster
and gus
dt chavez
great job gentlemen now let's see what
our judge thought come on over
sit
what are you kidding me you look like a
couple of rodeo clowns up there
nothing was in sync your hairstyles are
ridiculous
you butchered a terrific song and it's
time you went home
please spare us additional torture
and just euthanize yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
a cop i am not i'm just good at
observation but with shortcuts and cons
and the proper presentation they believe
that i can raise a finger to my head
see the past read a mind and can mingle
with the dead and sure my girls deceive
but that web's already weaved
woven weavied
the key is that i'm in too deep to turn
back now so i tell these lies
under santa barbara skies
[Music]
[Applause]
yes i know and i really don't care
so it's bound to explode funny business
we're conducting lighten up
we're all good would you please stop
interrupting all i know is just me
always cleaning up the mess while your
hair gets the credit getting people to
confess that's why i moisturize
understand about the skies of the matter
is it's all good fun
till an eye comes out i do
what i have to for my own safety and
legality
cause technically it's a felony
[Music]
it's just a faith it's a crime they
won't care yes don't mind and we'll
probably do time over there is my dad
here to offer his assistance
[Music]
yeah not happening with
occasional resistance until we face it
alone all this dark and dirty scheming
hope it's not
like the time that my partner went off
screaming
when i fought no you hit no i didn't yes
you did i'm just trying not to be the
one who died
under santa barbara
santa barbara
santa bats shoes
the spirits are telling me that he went
directly across the street into the park
into the woods spirits
are telling him he's a psychic and who
believes this
most of us honey doctor you too
will soon believe
[Music]
hello my name is sean spencer
this is my partner lil wayne
the evidence is underwhelming
but my intuition is insane
[Applause]
a trained observer misses nothing
each imperfection is a trail
it's not a question of if or where
but when the guilty party goes to jail
come with me the park the bus the park
the bus the spirits are sticklers just
check
with gus there is no way i'm wrong about
this
i've heard it both ways the right way
and then yours i've heard it both ways
let's not open any souls i've heard it
right and wrong
don't cheat my chong anymore
fellas it's so hard to say goodbye just
like the old days minus the hair and the
satin
it's so hard to
say goodbye to
yesterday
bob's your uncle it's working why can't
we get the last strip there were four of
us sean we're missing the harmony
i got it i'll do it
it's so hard to
say goodbye to
[Music]
yesterday
oh that can't be wait a second
that's the rat who is that let's go
[Music]
babies
swing low swing low
sweet chairs
coming for to carry me
home home
i looked over jordan and what did i
see coming forth to carry me home
a band of angels coming after me
coming for to carry me home if
you get there before i do
come after carry me home tell all my
friends i'm coming to coming forth to
carry me home
i want to be
i can't believe you've been holding out
on me for all these years you know it's
one of my lifelong dreams to be part of
a four piece singing group
five piece is my backup now i find out
not only were you in one you let it all
slip away i must know why i must
enough sean that was like a new edition
reunion concert minus bobby and ronnie
what could have possibly come between
men capable of creating such sweet sweet
harmony
give me a hint man you can give me a
baby hint
all right fine man i wish i could have
known you when you were black
you